cnn's chris cuomo is outed as a key
figure in his brother's defense despite
that cnn gig joe biden announces he
won't be visiting waukesha and jack
dorsey is out at twitter i'm ben shapiro
this is the bench bureau show
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
don't let big tech track what you do
anonymize your web browsing at
expressvpn.com
ben we'll get to all the news in just a
moment first you don't have to wait for
christmas in order to start saving big
on your christmas gifts what could you
do for somebody that would save them
hundreds of dollars hundreds of dollars
over the course of the year well you
could urge them to switch over to pure
talk usa if you want to do something
really smart this month i'm gonna give
you the life hack that cuts your cell
phone bill in half it is indeed pure
talk pure talk gives you killer 5g
coverage on one of the largest 5g
networks in the country and still saves
the average family over 800 a year i
made the switch the coverage is
excellent their us-based customer
service actually cares about you and
pure tax prices pretty much wholesale
unlimited talk tech six gigs of data for
just 30 bucks a month keep your number
keep your phone or this month get black
friday prices on new phones like the
iphone 12 for just 479 dollars you've
got a 30 day risk free guarantee so you
literally have nothing to lose head on
over to puretalk.com shop for the plan
and phone that are right for you and
then enter promo code shapiro you will
save 50 off your very first month of
coverage and save on a new phone that is
puretalk.com promo code shapiro puretalk
is simply smarter wireless some
restrictions apply see site for details
get started right now puretalk.com promo
code shapiro alrighty so
the most trusted name in news cnn every
night features chris cuomo and here is
the problem with that chris cuomo is a
terrible reporter he's not a reporter at
all he's an activist just like don lemon
is an activist just like anderson cooper
is an activist chris cuomo however has
now been embroiled for months on end in
the scandal involving his brother andrew
cuomo the former governor of new york
who was not ousted from his position as
governor of new york for killing every
old person in new york by shipping covet
positive elderly people back into
nursing homes and then covering it up no
he got ousted from his job because he
couldn't keep his hands off ass that's
basically why andrew cuomo is no longer
the governor of new york and kathy hokel
the current governor of new york
continues to just fail upward she only
takes positions abandoned by men who get
caught in sexual peccadillos of some
sort or another so
andrew cuomo is out there may still be
legal liability that attaches to andrew
cuomo but chris cuomo has been able to
sit there despite his myriad failures of
coverage during his brother's scandal
and he's been able to just occupy that
seat over at cnn no fuss no mas there is
one big problem with this chris cuomo
was actively facilitating his brother's
attempted cover-ups of the ass grabbage
according to the new york times today
chris cuomo played an outsized role in
ex-governor cuomo's defense
who could have suspected that not fredo
would have done this
i mean so remember chris cuomo was the
guy so intelligent that he once said
that saying that he is like fredo
corleone like the dumber brother in the
corleone family that saying that is an
anti-italian slur on the order of using
the n-word that's how intelligent chris
cuomo is block of wood chris cuomo well
not fredo over here it turns out was
willing to go to the mattresses for his
brother
according to the new york times
thousands of pages of new evidence and
sworn testimony released on monday show
the extent to which former governor
andrew cuomo relied on a group of allies
including his younger brother cnn host
chris cuomo to strategize how to deflect
and survive a cascade of sexual
harassment charges that eventually
engulfed him beginning last december
with the first public accusation by a
former aide lindsey boylan the records
lay out in unvarnished detail how a
tight-knit group of advisors discussed a
series of increasingly drastic steps to
manipulate the press discredit his
accusers and retain a grip on power that
became a less and less tenable after
debating the legality of the move they
agreed to pass miss boylan's personnel
file to reporters portraying her as
politically motivated and unhinged they
sought and failed to rally dozens of
former female aides and supporters to
pen and op-ed defending him now that in
and of itself would be pretty scummy
except for the fact that we've seen that
playbook before and it really is up to
the media whether to buy the playbook
what i mean by that is that if bill
clinton was useful they not only bought
the playbook they just repeated the
playbook verbatim
if however bill clinton is no longer
useful then bill clinton is a terrible
person who never should have been
president same thing for andrew cuomo if
this hits in the middle of kovid mania
last year then we just ignore it and
pretend it doesn't exist then if it
outlives coven mania then we just feel
like it's a good time to get rid of
andrew cuomo because he's kind of a
liability anyway given the fact that
again he basically just dumped all the
elderly and open graves
according to the new york times chris
cuomo pressed to take on a greater role
in crafting his brother's defense
including phoning into strategy calls
and using his media contacts to keep
tabs on reporters pursuing stories about
the owner at one point he even ran down
a second hand tip that another woman
accusing the governor of unwanted
advances at a wedding was lying she was
not
you need to trust me chris cuomo pled
with melissa de rosa the governor's
secretary at one point in march arguing
that she should rely on him and other
outside advisors like the political
consultant liz smith and the pollster
jeffrey by the way liz smith was
also a consultant for pete buttigieg and
um
she was texting people that christine
blasey ford was looney tunes at the same
time the people who judge was out there
like out front talking about how he
believed christine blasey ford
probably his chief assistant was telling
the cuomos that she was looney tunes
which just shows you how politically
motivated every single thing is when it
comes to the metoo movement
said chris cuomo to melissa to rosa we
are making mistakes we can't afford
cnn said on monday that the
investigative documents deserve a
thorough review and consideration quote
we will be having conversations and
seeking additional clarity about their
significance as they relate to cnn over
the next several days the company said
in a statement now remember cnn has
spent every waking moment of the last
several years suggesting that fox news
is simply a propaganda outlet on behalf
of donald trump and the republican party
here you literally have one of their
anchors who's the brother of perhaps the
most celebrated governor in america by
cnn last year he was doing comedy bits
smothers brothers comedy hour on cnn
every night with his brother governor of
new york while advising him on how to
track down women who are accusing his
brother of playing grab ass
and cnn's like well we'll investigate it
or you could fire him
you know just like you would anyone else
but it doesn't take all that much to
keep a job at cnn you don't even have to
keep honestly it's not just that you you
can cover up for your brother's
malfeasance or try to help him cover up
for his own sexual peccadillos you don't
even have to keep your hands off your
own junk
on on camera i mean jeffrey toobin still
has a job over at cnn like the standards
over there are unbelievably low
even though brian stelter will will
maintain that they remain a very very
trusted name for most americans we'll
get to more on chris cuomo
not fredo over here in just one second
first if you're a business owner it can
be a tough time to hire top talent for
your team especially when you're
competing with other businesses to find
the right people right now we have
something like 10 million open jobs and
a bunch of people are just not filling
them and there are only a few million
people who are actually applying for
those jobs a lot of competition for
those open jobs so how do you get the
best employee well you use zip recruiter
their invite to apply feature lets you
invite the best candidates to apply for
your open roles right now you can try it
for free at ziprecruiter.com dailywire
how does invite to apply work well when
you post a job on zip recruiter you
start getting the most qualified people
sent to you pretty quickly then you can
easily review recommended candidates and
invite your top choices to apply with
one click next key marketing manager
erin hartchi loves invite to apply she
said they get my job posting in front of
the right people i instantly see great
candidates and i can invite them to
apply to my job in fact according to zip
recruiter internal data on average for
2020 jobs where employers use that
invite to apply feature from zip
recruiter get two and a half times more
candidates that helps them make the
hiring process much faster and more
efficient see for yourself just go to
this exclusive web address
ziprecruiter.com
dailywire at ziprecruiter.com
d-a-i-l-y-w-i-r-e
to try zip recruiter for free that is
zippercrew.com daily wires of recruiter
is indeed the smartest way to hire
alrighty so
the previously unseen material according
to the new york times including video of
the former governor answering questions
under oath were produced earlier this
year by investigators working for
latisha james new york's attorney
general who of course issued this report
solely in order to clear the path for
her own gubernatorial run remember
everything here is corrupt everything
andrew cuomo is corrupt chris cuomo is
corrupt letitia james is corrupt all of
them are corrupt these are the people
you want to give more power over your
life you want them to control whether
you can go to your place of business and
whether you have to force your employees
to vacs
these people these dumb asses
miss james had already released
transcripts of an 11-hour interview with
mr cuomo and interviews with 10 women
who had accused him of a range of
misconduct in a statement after monday's
release richard azzapardi a spokesman
for the former governor accused james
who is now running for governor of
acting out of political malice for cuomo
i mean that that is true he said to the
surprise of no one tisch james continues
abusing her government power to leverage
her political future prosecutorial
misconduct ethics and integrity be
damned today's manipulated release of
hand-picked witness testimony with
selective redactions is typical
and honestly
all the stuff they're saying about each
other is true everything they say about
themselves is false leticia james is not
a warrior for truth andrew cuomo was not
a good governor or a good person
and everything they say about each other
is 100 true leticia james saying that
that andrew cuomo is a garbage bag and
andrew cuomo replying that she's a
politically motivated hack all of those
things are true whenever in politics
people insult each other the insults are
generally true and the stuff they say
about themselves is generally false
i trust no one said mr rosa
by way of explaining why she and not an
assistant was sharing colin's details
for a strategy call
in another message released by
investigators derosa describes berating
two people including one nicknamed
sponge who is among mr cuomo's accusers
i'm on a real role she said adding in my
defense everyone sucks
in one instance investigators asked mr
as a party to say whether or not the
governor had ever pelted him with
apricots in a fit of rage
he claimed the story which was relayed
in the testimony of another unnamed
staff member was false are you serious
as the party said but he also testified
he's yelled at me i failed back at him
but it was fine first of all
if if andrew cuomo pelts his lawyer with
apricots that is the best thing i've
ever heard about andrew cuomo like it
actually makes me like andrew cuomo
anybody who pelts their lawyer with
apricots
basically deserves to be governor
forever no matter what else they have
done i think
one of the people who was very involved
was chris cuomo according to the new
york times who appears to have played a
larger role than he has admitted to or
has previously been known
as the situation started to accelerate
my brother asked me to be in the loop
chris cuomo told investigators in a
six-hour interview last july he said he
saw himself as a satellite of his
brother's more formal advisors
he insisted to investigators he had
never manipulated coverage or spun other
journalists to benefit his brother
he has told viewers of his show he acted
only as a brother to be a sounding board
to listen and to offer my take advising
his brother to tell the truth whatever
it was and eventually to resign yeah i
don't believe that as a working
journalist with a vast network of
sources in and outside of media chris
cuomo proved to be more useful to those
trying to help the governor cling to
power according to text messages emails
and testimony collected by investigators
he also argued strenuously against his
brother resigning before a full
investigation was conducted when mr rosa
was trying to keep tabs in early march
on journalists working to uncover
stories of harassment she turned to
chris cuomo for intel on it he wrote
back after one such request a few days
later mr rosa wrote to the governor's
brother she had heard ronan farrow of
the new yorker was getting ready to move
a story can you check your sources
chris cuomo said he was in a panic over
how the governor's team was handling the
accusations he pledged to quote let me
help with prep before drafting his own
proposed statements for the governor to
read including one referencing cancel
culture he also used his contacts to try
to aid the defense in other ways after
the new york times reported in early
march that the governor had made an
unwanted advance on a young woman at a
wedding chris cuomo texted deroza to say
quote i have a lead on the wedding girl
who he believed had potentially been put
up to it to hurt the governor
the lead turned out to be bunk he told
investigators
so again
chris cuomo deeply involved in the
defense so what does this mean it means
that no one is trustworthy that's what
it means and chris cuomo again has not
been summarily canned by cnn after all
these revelations we've known for a long
time that chris was deeply involved in
his brother's defense listen on a
familial level
i really don't see a huge issue with
brothers trying to defend each other i
don't
i in fact i think there's something kind
of nice about it what i will say is that
you don't get to be an anchor on cnn
covering the news every night while
ignoring one of the biggest news stories
in the country that you happen to have
inside information about you don't get
to do that you want to take a leave of
absence from cnn to advise your brother
that's fine you want to be an advisor to
your brother in the middle of an
investigation into how many butts he was
grabbing at wedding parties and uh you
should not be on air at the time but
there are really no standards over at
cnn at all in fact last night chris
cuomo went on air he had nothing to say
about this entire thing and at the end
of his show he always does this weird
crossover with don lemon where don lemon
and chris cuomo do a bit of a jokey
hokey routine and don lemon talked about
how much he loves chris cuomo which
makes sense because don lemon himself is
a political hack
it's good to see you good to see you i
know you had a great thanksgiving i hope
you did i missed you i am grateful for
your friendship and your love i think
that you are fantastic
one of the kindest people i know on this
planet
there you go i meant everywhere i am
thankful for you and my life it was
great to see you having a good time i
like the friendsgiving uh tradition yes
uh for us it was great to be in the
house uh for the first time and uh it
was all good man one memory at a time
it's always better with you but it was
good to know you were having fun where
you were okay so that's the coverage
last night on cnn
do you trust your news sources
why why should you trust your news
sources they are propaganda outlets
you're just gonna have to pick which
propaganda outlet you like by the way
how propagandistic are these news
outlets new york magazine is now
producing a book of essays on aoc
i'm not kidding it's called take up
space the unprecedented aoc they should
have called it so fresh so face the aoc
story
apparently the book will include a
series of essays on the wonders of aoc
including an essay on the role her
beauty plays in her public perception by
rhonda geralic analysis of her social
media greatest hits by madison malone
kircher and an essay on her rare
authenticity by molly fisher by the way
i love the notion that the
aoc machine which is just a production
machine
and honestly all credit to her she's as
produced as any hollywood star
the fact that she is being treated as a
voice of authenticity is hysterically
funny but this is what your media is
this is who your media are
and it has predictable consequences like
the obscuring of basic facts we'll get
to that in just one second first let's
talk about the perfect gift for the
holidays i'm talking about the gift of
steak okay every dude on your list wants
steak i'm just telling you right now
there will be no greater gift this year
than steak your go to as a dude for the
women in your life is generally jewelry
but let me just tell you for guys steak
is like it's unbeatable and omaha steaks
makes the best steaks the holidays are
around the corner finding the perfect
gift is tricky omaha steaks makes it
easy to send friends and family an
unforgettable gift guaranteed to be
loved go to omahasteaks.com and enter
shapiro into the search bar to order the
perfect gift package for 99.99 you get
24 entrees like the world famous bacon
wrapped filet mignons chicken breast
sides desserts and so much more when you
use code shapiro you'll also get an
additional eight omaha steaks burgers
for free with your order
you've heard the reports about shortages
and shipping delays don't wait order the
perfect gift package today at
omahasteaks.com you'll get eight free
burgers when entering the code shapiro
achieve at gifting greatness with the
omaha steaks incredible flavor
incredible value 100 guaranteed
omahastakes.com
keyword shapiro go check them out right
now every dude on your list is going to
be very happy for the holidays with
omaha steaks okay
speaking of the media and their
untrustworthiness i'm just going to
remind you that last week a black 39
year old man ran a car into the middle
of a parade of small children and
elderly grandmothers and killed a bunch
of them and the entire media have
completely forgotten about it and these
are your trusted institutional sources
we're going to tell you what you need to
do on a day-to-day level like everything
you need to know is going to come from
these people
except for how they just obscure facts
on a regular basis
it's completely disappeared from the
news by the way waukesha completely
disappeared from can you i wonder why
why did wakasha completely disappear
from the news so
you still remember how there was a woman
named heather heyer who was killed in
charlottesville by a white supremacist
driving a car into a parade you remember
this right you remember because it was a
national story it is still a national
story it will be used as a campaign
issue in 2024 should donald trump run
again
you remember that right okay that was a
big thing it was a big issue it was a
real act of evil crime
the person in waukesha killed six times
as many people
and no one seems to care anymore even
though
the man's social media is filled with
anti-white rage blm nonsense and
actual quotes from hitler
and we are supposed to pretend that that
doesn't matter at all because the media
have decided it's no longer of issue it
was an suv
apparently an unmanned suv i thought
that those weren't being rolled out
completely on american roads for a while
but apparently they are and they just
run people down to parades it's pretty
incredible
by the way quick note
you want to know why this is not in the
media it's not in the media because the
left doesn't want it in the media they
don't want to cover this anymore it's
over
how do i know that the left don't want
it in the media because
joe biden clearly doesn't jennsocki over
at the white house was asked why joe
biden is not visiting waukesha the
victims
of what appears to be a deliberate
criminal act of homicide according to
the cops why is he not going and
visiting with the victims and uh you
know shenzhaki says you know he's busy
he's a busy guy he's a busy guy sleeping
in his basement drinking in shore and
and mumbling to himself
our hearts go out to this community to
the people in waukesha that we've been
in touch obviously with officials there
and we're all watching as people are
recovering and this is such a difficult
time of year for for this to happen it's
difficult any time
obviously any president going to visit a
community requires a lot of assets
requires taking their resources and
it's not something that i have a
previewed at this point point in time
but we remain in touch with local
officials and certainly our our hearts
are with the community as they've gone
through such a difficult time now um i
would take that a little more seriously
except for the fact that your entire
campaign decided to descend on kenosha
after a career criminal named jacob
blake was alleged to have raped a woman
showed up at her house she called the
cops the cops showed up he resisted
arrest he had a knife on him he refused
to obey their commands and he was shot
and joe biden showed up so did kamala
harris they all decided to make phone
calls and show up in person in kenosha
at the behest of a career criminal with
a resisted arrest so i find it rather
unconvincing that the reason you're not
showing up in waukesha is because
suddenly you are concerned with cost
issues
this is the greatest spending president
in the history of the united states by a
long shot
and you are
the guy who is saying that you're
concerned about cost issues or could it
be you really don't like this particular
crime story it's gonna be a local crime
story again remember this is the rule
the rule is that if there is a crime
that backs the national left-wing
narrative then it's a national crime
story if it's a crime that does not back
the national left-wing narrative then
it's a local crime story it's a local
crime story right kermit gosnell
an abortionist who is murdering babies
after they were born in philadelphia by
the dozens that was a local crime story
however if somebody sends a a death
threat to a democratic member of
congress that is a national crime story
that's the way this works if a if a
bernie sanders acolyte shoots up a bunch
of republican congress people that's a
national news story for like a day
however
if there are a bunch of people who break
into the capitol building on january 6th
that's a national news story forever
now i'm not saying that
the ones that i just mentioned there
that are national news stories should
not be i'm saying that many of the ones
they call local news stories ought to be
national news stories but your media are
driven by just as chris cuomo acts at
the behest of his brother andrew cuomo
so too the left-wing media at the behest
of their brothers in the democratic
party to suggest that the media and the
democratic party are somehow
unaffiliated is an absurdity piled on
top of an absurdity
this is a point that was made by ron
desantis the governor of florida who has
been taking the lead in fighting the
battle against the media here in the
state of florida kerry was
doing a doing a
presser with a bunch of members of law
enforcement because florida is a
fantastic state and here is a ronda
sanchez talking about waukesha is that
how it works the suvs they just drive by
themselves this just kind of happened
and they say oh this was a big accident
you never actually hear the discussion
about who committed this
what was the motivation
this guy was a career criminal let out
on didn't really have any bail basically
should not have even been on the street
uh had clear
anti-white animus
and this was an intentional act and it
seems like you know for corporate press
they're more apt to characterize a
parent who goes to a school board
meeting to protest bad policies as a
domestic terrorist than somebody who
intentionally rams an suv into a crowd
of innocent people so you have at least
six have died you have many more that
have been injured i know many people are
in the hospital and so uh let's just be
clear this was not a car just driving in
this is correct this is correct
hey he he continued along these lines he
said this is an attack by a felon who
did that who should not have been on the
street we'll see what the actual
motivation was it very well may have
been in response to what happened with
kyle rittenhouse you have to wonder if
that's the case almost surely this guy's
view of written house was colored by all
the media lies he brought a rifle across
state lines that was a lie they said the
initial altercation with jacob black
that blake was unarmed that's a lie they
covered up blake's criminal history
correct correct so why would you trust
these members of the media anywhere
along the line by the way the latest
crime story that will not be a national
story is uh the jesse smalley the jesse
smallett trial in chicago remember the
entire media jumped to the conclusion
the absurd conclusion that justice
millett was telling the truth when he
said last year that he was walking on
the streets of chicago at 3 am in a
windstorm and a bunch of maggot-hatted
idiots came up behind him and garretted
him
it was a lie it turns out that allegedly
he had hired two of his buddies to do
this to him and then he had lied to the
cops about it specifically for the media
attention
now there's a trial of jesse smallat
happening according to the associated
press he's a real victim of a real crime
according to his attorney
it turns out the two brothers who
attacked malet in january didn't like
him a 3 500 check the actor paid the men
was for training so he could prepare for
an upcoming music video he wasn't paying
them so that they would fake a crime
involving him
and we'll see how long that lasts in the
news the jesse smallheck case the entire
me if it had been a true story that's a
national news story but it wasn't a true
story he was lying so uh now it's a
local crime story again that is how all
of this works consistently and
continuously alrighty coming up we're
gonna get to the situation with lauren
bobert and ilhan omar we'll get to that
in just one moment first let us talk
about the fact that you need life
insurance let's say for example that you
are a psychologist and you specialize in
in child psychology and a kid comes to
you and he explains to you that he has
been seeing people who are no longer
with us he has been seeing people who
are dead and you start working with the
kid and it's it's really terrifying and
strange very strange situation well
right about the time that you realize
that you actually died a while ago you
started thinking man if i had known that
i would have bought life insurance a
long time ago long before i ever met
this kid i should have listened to
shapiro and gone to policy genius policy
genius makes getting a life insurance
quote easy first you head on over to
policygenius.com shapiro answer a few
questions about yourself in minutes you
can work out how much life insurance
coverage you need compare personalized
quotes to find your best price you could
say 50 or more on life insurance by
comparing quotes with policy genius
their license experts will help you
understand your options and apply for a
policy the policy genius team works for
you not the insurance companies you can
trust them to offer unbiased help
advocate for you at every step until you
are covered
policy genius doesn't add on extra fees
or sell your information to third
parties they have thousands of five star
reviews across google and trust pilot
since 2014 policy genius has helped over
30 million people shop for insurance
head on over to policygenius.com shapiro
get your free life insurance quotes see
how much you could save that's
policygenius.com
shapiro alrighty so meanwhile
file this one under why would you ever
trust politicians to do anything about
your life i really
it is a source of constant bewilderment
that you look at the institutional
players in your life and you think these
people need more authority they need
more authority
because let's just face it most of the
people are in congress at this point are
there for the instagram of it they're
there for the public attention of it
and they're not super competent at their
jobs and so i don't take them very
seriously because i don't think that
they're worthy of being taken seriously
this goes across the board okay it seems
to me that whenever you see congress
people who are pretending to be offended
by each other it's all for show
whether it is aoc on the floor of the
house yelling about how
what what the hell what the hell is that
that congressman's name from arizona
gosar well whether it was aoc standing
on the floor of congress shouting about
how paul gosar threatened her life with
an anime meme or whether it is ilhan
omar complaining that lauren bolbert
made up made a bad and cruel joke about
her being a terrorist i just i i i find
a ha i'm having a hard time carrying i
got to be honest with you i have a real
hard time with congress people who spend
their lives complaining that people make
fun of them
and use anime memes like welcome to the
real world where this kind of crap
happens all the time
yeah i'm i'm not aware of many public
figures who receive more of this stuff
than i do and frankly i don't care
because i have a real life and you know
what i can do i can shut off my phone
and if somebody says something mean and
nasty about me eh that's life
but these congress people are
simultaneously some of the biggest mouth
thin skinned people i've ever seen in my
entire life and it's so obnoxious so
we've had an entire national controversy
now over the fact that lauren bobert did
a did an event
where she made a joke about ilhan omar a
mildly inappropriate joke about how she
said that ilhan omar was a was a bomber
or something
okay now is that a joke that politicians
should tell about each other no probably
not
is it the end of the world is it
something that you should spend even one
iota of energy on today no and frankly
if we are going to rank
crimes by congress members i'm going to
go with the congress member who says
openly anti-semitic things routinely who
has expressed support for terror groups
who has written letters to judges
attempting to lessen the sentence of
people who are being recruited to isis i
feel like that's a lot worse than lauren
bover making a bad joke about that
person i'm just gonna put that out there
okay but apparently this is now such an
issue the democrats are considering
stripping lauren bobert of her committee
assignment
now let's just be real about this
democrats have entered into a game that
they do not want to play because
congress will be controlled by
republicans come january 2023 and when
that happens ilhan omar will not be on
the foreign affairs committee eric
swallow will not be on the intelligence
committee since he was banging a chinese
spy we are not going to be having a lot
of the democratic members of congress
who are currently sitting maxine waters
is not going to be on financial services
that lady is corrupt as the day is long
now the rule was it used to be that
parties got to select which of their own
members got to sit on which committee
that rule is in place because you really
didn't want one party dictating to the
other party who its prominent members
would be
but democrats have broken that rule
because they've stripped a bunch of
republican congress members of their
committee assignments even if i think
those members are bad i don't think it's
up to democrats to strip the opposing
party of their committee assignment so
if we're going to play this game because
now democrats want to do this to lauren
bober over this joke that we're about to
play for you then um ilhan omar is
likely to find herself out in the cold
come january 2023 as she should be so
anyway here is the original joke that
lauren bobert told obviously so bad so
terrible end of world let's all weep for
ilhan omar
i was getting into an elevator with one
of my staffers
and he and i are we're leaving the
capitol we're going back to my office
and we get an elevator and i see a
capital police officer
running hurriedly
to the elevator i see fret all over his
face and he's reaching and i'm like what
the door's shutting like i can't i can't
open it like what's happening
i look to my left and there she is
ilhan omar
and i said well
she doesn't have a backpack we should be
fine
okay uh so she makes a joke about el
hanar being being a terrorist or
whatever
okay so ilhan omar acts like she is very
very upset about this how dare anybody
how dare anybody
a woman who once said that something
happened on 9 11 something happened to
some people on 9 11. she's never said
anything offensive oh han omar again
does that mean that lauren bobert told
the world's greatest joke there is that
a joke that she should apologize for you
know on a personal level the way that
this typically should work is she should
call up you know i don't think she owes
the public an apology i think that
there's this routine in politics now
where if you say something mean to
somebody you don't know them an apology
you owe the public an apology you don't
know the public in apology i think the
public can take care of itself but you
know she called up
she called up bill and omar to try and
be a nice person and offered her an
apology and apparently ilhan omar then
played the wrong to innocent and uh and
hung up on her here is lauren bober
telling that story
she said that she still wanted a public
apology because what i had done wasn't
good enough so i reiterated to her what
i had just said she kept asking for a
public apology so i told ilhan omar that
she should make a public apology to the
american people for her anti-american
anti-semitic anti-police rhetoric she
continued to press and i continued to
press back and then representative omar
hung up on me rejecting an apology and
hanging up on someone is part of cancel
culture 101 and a pillar of the democrat
party
okay so
me
so there are there'll be a lot of words
spilled over this a lot of ink spilled
over this a lot of talk about democrats
are now seriously considering again
stripping lauren boulder for committee
assignment over this over the like
all right i mean like i'm i'm not going
to pretend that i care at all because i
frankly do not i do not i do love how
old and omar characterized this
conversation quote today i graciously
accepted a call from representative
lauren well i mean don't pat herself on
the back too hard there lady i mean her
arm has stretched six inches just so she
could properly reach her back she had
graciously she didn't just accept a
phone call she graciously accepted a
phone call what a hero what a hero in
the hope of receiving a direct apology
for falsely claiming she met me in an
elevator suggesting i was a terrorist
and for a history of anti-muslim hate
instead of apologizing for islamophobic
comments and fabricated lies
representative boba refused to publicly
acknowledge her hurtful and dangerous
comments she instead doubled down on her
rhetoric and i decided to end the
unproductive call i believe in engaging
with those we disagree with respectfully
no you don't in what world is this true
of ilhoon omar but not when that
disagreement is rooted in outright
bigotry and okay so here is the dynamic
dynamic in congress is that our congress
people have every incentive to be social
media stars and very little incentive to
actually just do public service
and so
this benefits everybody in the end this
benefits everybody it benefits people
who tell edgy jokes it benefits people
who get very offended it benefits the
media that loves to cover it
does any of it make your life better of
course not and should you spend one
again one ounce of energy over the
offense being taken by members of
congress that other members of congress
are saying mean things about them not
one shred of energy should you spend
today on this not one shred so i only
wish to point this out because i wish to
point out that you the american people
have decided to give more of these
people power over your life and i don't
understand why i will never understand
why speaking of people who have power
over your life and also don't deserve
power over your life there's a new book
that is coming out titled laptop from
hell hunter biden big tech and the dirty
secrets the president tried to hide by a
new york post columnist named miranda
devine she says while joe biden waged
war on white privilege from the white
house his own family was the living
embodiment of the worst of it joe has
always made sure the bidens lived a life
of unearned privilege and entitlements
under his beneficent patronage like
members of hereditary aristocracy the
bidens would have access to the best
america can give most prestigious
educational institutions internships
clerkship scholarships directorships and
government syndicates
decades ago the president decided that
hunter biden would act as the family's
cash cow says divine hunter who would
have preferred to be an artist or a
writer was assigned the role of paying
the bills for the rest of the family
through lucrative grace and favor jobs
and sweetheart deals facilitated by
joe's network of connections in delaware
and later throughout the world in
addition to records from his missing
laptop showing hunter held ten percent
of chinese business to deal
of a chinese business deal for the big
guy divine quotes an email hunter wrote
to his oldest starter naomi in 2019
quote i hope you can all do what i did
and pay for everything for this entire
family for 30 years it's really hard but
don't worry unlike pop i won't make you
give me half your salary hunter later
alleged allegedly complained to his aunt
who raised him after his mother's tragic
death that although joe biden co-signed
student loans for hunter and bow he
expected hunter to pay off both loans
dad never paid one dime hunter wrote in
an email according to the book
devine says she found evidence that joe
biden benefited from hunter's deals in
multiple emails such as one concerning
jrb bills in another email detailed by
divine dated april 12 2018 hunter gets
locked out of one of his wells fargo
accounts because quote my dad has been
using most lines on this account which
i've through the gracious offerings of
eric schwerin a close family advisor
have paid for the past 11 years when
schwerin writes about the amount of
money in my account his scare quotes
imply its contents belong to him in name
only
so in other words the biden family has
been engaged in a grift in which they
used hunter as basically their cutout
for years and years and years and years
and these are the politicians that we
trust they're all grifters
so many of them are grifters on on all
sides of the aisle by the way
but the the
notion from media is that you ought to
again give them more and more and more
trust they're not disconnected from the
american public by the way speaking of
being disconnected from the american
public just want to know quickly be
booty judge who democrats are now
touting as a possible replacement for
kamala harris should joe biden go down
before 2024
p booty judge yesterday man of the
people pete booty judge from south bend
indiana who can afford to take two
months of paternity leave based on the
grave of physical
harms experienced by him and his spouse
during the birth of their child he
needed paternity leave for two months in
the middle of a supply chain crisis we
were all supposed to not notice
and um and now p booty judge has such
sympathy for the american people that he
says you shouldn't worry so much about
gas prices after all you can buy
electric vehicles electric vehicles by
the way are going for like 40 50 000 a
pop if you just families got that lying
around sure pete makes perfect sense
most of the physical infrastructure work
uh was contemplated in the bill that was
just signed but there is more envisioned
in the build back better law i'll give
you one example it contains incentives
to make it more affordable to buy an
electric vehicle up to a 12 500 discount
in effect for families thinking about
getting an ev families that once they
own that electric vehicle will never
have to worry about gas prices again
well i mean if you buy an electric
vehicle you'll never have to worry about
gas again sure you're driving a beat-up
1997 honda civic and uh you're just
attempting to get to work and you're
making 45 000 a year but for that entire
salary and a little bit you could
probably get an electric vehicle
i mean sure you wouldn't be able to feed
your family this year but you could get
an electric vehicle according p booty
judge
these are the folks you have elected
these are the folks you have decided to
put in charge of your life already
coming up we'll get to jack dorsey who
is now out at twitter to spend more time
with his beard first let's talk about
the fact that if you are looking at
redoing your home and beautifying your
home one of the biggest things that i
care about when i look at my house is
the way light enters my home you know
natural light really beautifies your
home and one of the big obstacles to
that is if you have crappy old window
coverings and when you decided to rent
that apartment when you decided to buy
that house you probably didn't think
much about the window coverings but now
that i'm saying it you're looking at it
aren't you well you should just get
those things replaced and you can do it
the best way possible with blinds.com
get your home ready for guests over the
holidays with new window treatments from
blinds.com that make the entire process
super simple you will love the result
make blinds.com your first choice for
high quality window coverings that are
perfect for any size window there's no
guesswork no hassle with multiple trips
to a store or trying to meet up with a
contractor or interior designer to
consult you who's really just going to
try and upsell you all the window
treatments from blinds.com come at a
great price and are easy to install you
can handle the measure and install
yourself or have blinds.com take care of
it with local pros
and blinds.com they're the experts you
want to go to they've got 25 million
windows covered over 40 000 5 star
reviews get free samples free shipping
100 satisfaction guarantee
go to blinds.com right now through
december 1st save up to 45 off
everything plus premium door busters and
additional savings off your entire order
that's blinds.com for up to 45 percent
off when you check out online don't
forget to tell them you heard about
blinds.com from the ben shapiro show
rules and restrictions may apply
alrighty folks if you didn't tune in to
tucker's show last night you might have
missed my colleagues super important and
exciting announcement matt walsh is now
a wildly successful children's book
author yes matt walsh he's just written
his first children's book the book is
called johnny the walrus it's about a
little boy named johnny with a big
imagination whether he's a big scary
dinosaur or a knight in shining armor or
a playful puppy he's always playing
pretend but one day he's forced to make
a decision between the little boy he is
and his big imagination and he's not
allowed to change his mind it's a tale
of identity and imagination it's waiting
for you to purchase it on amazon right
now so please head on over to
johnnythewalrus.com pick up a copy of
matt walsh's timely masterpiece johnny
the walrus today you're listening to the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
meanwhile over at twitter we here on the
conservative side of the aisle we've
been bashing jack dorsey for a very long
time because he's a political hack he's
a wild left-wing activist you remember
he used to do full events with deray
mckesson a black lives matter back in
2015 and uh also he's a weird guy right
he's the kind of guy who goes over to
malaysia and just goes to like a
malaysian cave and hangs out with the
mosquitoes that he can demonstrate that
he's a spiritualist and also he's grown
a beard a la ben gunn so he can live on
treasure island and and try to try to uh
you know
help
hawking
and and long john silver he's he's a
very strange and odd and odd man uh well
he's now out at twitter the stock price
rose by like 10 when he resigned which
is always a great sign for your
leadership you say i'm out everybody's
like oh i want that stock now
well there's only one problem the person
who's about to replace jack dorsey as
the twitter ceo
is the cto the chief technology officer
whose name is parag agrawal
well there's only one problem with parag
agrawal if you didn't like jack dorsey
because he thought that he was too
restrictive that he had banned too many
people who are on the right side of the
aisle um agrawal is worse according to
national review twitter's incoming ceo
parag agrowall suggested last year the
company should focus less on free speech
during an interview with technology
review
twitter co-founder jack dorsey announced
monday he is stepping down as ceo and
will be succeeded by agrawal who's the
platform's current cto
last year technology review
editor-in-chief gideon litchfield asked
agrawal how twitter balances its efforts
to combat misinformation with quote
wanting to protect free speech as a core
value and here's what agrawal said quote
our role is not to be bound by the first
amendment but our role is to serve a
healthy public conversation and our
moves are reflective of things we
believe lead to a healthier public
conversation
the kinds of things we do about this is
focus less on thinking about free speech
but thinking about how the times have
changed
one of the changes today we see is
speech is easy on the internet he said
most people can speak where our role is
particularly emphasized is who can be
heard the scarce commodity today is
attention there's a lot of content out
there a lot of tweets out there not all
of it gets attention some subset of it
gets attention twitter's role he said is
moving toward how we recommend content
and that sort of is is a struggle that
we're working through in terms of how we
make sure these recommendation systems
that we're building how we direct
people's attention is leading to public
healthy conversation that is most
participatory
okay in other words we are going to
shift and control exactly the kind of
information you see so if you're worried
about twitter before under jack dorsey
now you have to worry twice as much
about that under the incoming twitter
ceo parag agrawal again remember these
are elites who have decided that they
are going to make for quote unquote
healthy conversation their definition of
healthy conversation is they get to
define the parameters of the
conversation they get to define the
terminology that they use they get to
define the the terminology you use they
get to define what allows you to remain
on twitter and what is not
one of our columnists here at uh daily
wire one of our reporters amanda presta
giacomo she was banned outright from
twitter for the great crime of having
called a biological male a biological
male
this is the kind of stuff that twitter
is going to be doing more and more in
the future they're simply going to be
deciding the overton window by
referencing the democratic party's most
radical line and then implementing it
top down and they will shadow ban people
they will be blocking people they will
be banning people outright they'll just
be closing that winner now that does
provide an opportunity for places like
parlor so long as places like parlor are
then not deplatformed by amazon web
services and this is where you get into
the real institutional threat to
american life today
and it's not all from the government
very often it is from corporations
working hand in glove with democratic
institutions and under threat from
democratic institutions in order to
restrict your ability to disseminate
information
because when you have all neutral
service providers like amazon web
services see platforming alternatives to
twitter like parlor which is what
happened earlier this year after january
6th when that sort of stuff happens what
you are basically saying is there is no
alternative but to use this sort of
language and abide by the rules set by
the cultural elites who disagree with
you on baseline things about how the
world should work
it's illegitimate and it's authoritarian
and you're gonna see more of that from
twitter with jack dorsey gone god help
us it's amazing i'm now forced into how
bad is the left i'm now forced into the
position of defending jack dorsey as
opposed to the person who's about to
succeed him
so the reason by the way that jack
dorsey said that he was leaving aside
from he has a desperate need to to meet
insects from other continents is uh he
said that um he needed to leave because
he didn't want to get in the way of the
of the company
he said i'm going to serve on the board
through my term to help perag and brett
brett would be brett taylor who's going
to become board chair with the
transition after that i'll leave the
board why not stare become chair i
believe it's important to give pereg the
space he needs to lead back to my
previous point i believe it's critical a
company can stand on its own free of its
founder's influence or direction i want
you all to know this is my decision and
i own it it's a tough one for me of
course i love this servicing company by
the way the actual reason dorsey is
leaving is apparently because he's very
into crypto which
so i like crypto as well
my deep concern is that i've seen too
many freedom-oriented institutions taken
over by people who do not actually have
freedom at their heart a jack dorsey
took over twitter and or he founded
twitter and his original goal was to
broaden the capacity for free speech and
soon enough he was shadow banning and
banning people outright
same thing with facebook
i did and if when it comes to bitcoin
which was an alternative to centralized
government control of currencies i just
have a feeling that a lot of the people
who are getting into crypto right now
are then going to harness it on behalf
of government and use it against you the
same way they've done with so many
social media outlets and this scares the
hell out of me if decentralization was
the wave of the future re-centralization
is the next step
and it seems to me that the jack
dorsey's of the world have been a
negative influence in that direction
unfortunately
alrighty meanwhile
the biden administration continues to
panic over omicron
omicron of course is the uh is the new
variation of the of the coven 19 virus
and we're all supposed to freak out and
panic over it there's a of course only
one problem with that which there's no
actual reason for the panic at this
point
yeah people by the way in free areas are
just ignoring this right down here in in
south florida we have art basil which is
the the big art festival down here and
no one is not going everybody's just
gonna go do whatever they want what's
amazing about this is that again these
scientists who are describing the new
covariance are saying that the symptoms
are mild
they're saying that there are more
mutations in terms of the spike proteins
which means that it may be more
transmissible but it may also be milder
i don't understand why that's not a good
thing like if i have a choice between
slightly less transmissible but still
but still really transmissible
and kills more people and more
transmissible but kills fewer people i
care about the latter right
i mean the form we just call a cold
right if if there's something that's
very transmissible and kills virtually
no one
that's okay if there's something that's
somewhat less transmissible but still
very transmissible and kills a ton of
people
that's that's a bad thing so one of the
things that nobody's talking about is
the possibility that oh
macron which apparently is more
transmissible might also be milder
if that's the case let's say it becomes
dominant we'll take crowds out delta
and let's say that it kills fewer people
it has a lower ifr than delta
why isn't that a positive like if i have
a choice between being infected with
omicron with a lower death rate and
delta with a higher death rate
why is it bad that omicron becomes the
dominant strain by the way that would
follow the pattern and viruses viruses
typically get less
less deadly and more virulent over time
and when they become endemic they become
easier to get but they also become less
deadly
that's something that the world can
survive and yet the world is treating
this thing with abject sheer terror and
panic
and at that point you start have to you
start having to doubt motives like again
i always attribute to stupidity rather
than malice but at this point in time
i'm having a hard time telling how this
is not malice
you still have a bunch of people in
positions of authority claiming that
they know how to shut down the virus
when they've spent a year and a half not
shutting down the virus
and then telling you that you should
panic in the absence of data
why
i just don't understand why
and by the way we should know very very
quickly dr marti makari was on the show
yesterday and he said we should know
basically within 48 hours whether the
vaccines and the antibodies stand up to
omicron in any serious way you know we
don't have any of that information why
is the data collection so bad
meanwhile the cdc has decided everybody
in america needs to get a third shot
based on what i have no idea
they're not they're not providing the
data that's why everybody needs a third
child i understand if you're
immunocompromised and elderly you need a
third child my parents got a third shot
i'm not sure why i need a third shot i'm
37 i'm fully vaccinated
and i'm healthy
why do i need a third child they
provided no data the idea is just you
have to listen to them and i'm sorry you
haven't earned my trust in fact you've
earned my distrust i trusted you more
before the pandemic than i do now all
right we'll be back here later today
with an additional hour of content
coming up soon the matt wall show airs
at 1 30 pm eastern go check out matt's
new children's book as well at
johnnythewalrus.com be sure to check out
matt's show at dailywire.com i'm ben
shapiro this is the bench bureau show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover production manager pawel
wydowsky associate producer bradford
carrington host producer justin barber
the show is edited by adam sci events
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant jessica kranz the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright dailywire 2021
on the matt wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture faith current
events all the fundamentals if they
matter to you come check out the show